en el círculo con centro en o que se
encuentra abajo y aquí tenemos nuestra
imagen de nuestro círculo concentró en y
ese es el segmento ese es un diámetro
entonces vamos a marcar el segmento s
aquí tenemos ese vamos a conectarlo con
ese segmento es un diámetro vamos a
hacer un poquito más grueso muy bien ahí
tenemos un diámetro verdad cuál es la
medida del ángulo e s
así que vamos a calcular la medida del
ángulo e s y entonces en realidad se
está refiriendo a este ángulo que
tenemos aquí sería este ángulo que
tenemos aquí es desconocido y como
siempre te invito a que hagas una pausa
y trates de resolver este problema por
tu propia cuenta
muy bien entonces este problema puede
abordarse desde distintos puntos de
vista digamos el primer punto de vista
que se me ocurre es que por ejemplo
tenemos aquí un montón de triángulos y
podemos usar el hecho de que la suma de
los ángulos internos de cualquier
triángulo es 180 grados así que
fijémonos primero en este triángulo de
aquí vamos a fijarnos en este triángulo
de aquí definido por los vértices s ii y
el vértice y muy bien y lo que vamos a
tratar de utilizar aquí es que conocemos
este ángulo verdad el ángulo que se
encuentra aquí es de 27 grados y ahora
si nosotros pudiéramos si nosotros
pudiéramos decir cuánto mide este ángulo
entonces podríamos calcular también cuál
es el ángulo que nos interesa verdad
porque la suma de los ángulos internos
de un triángulo es 180 grados así que
empecemos por calcular cuánto mide este
notemos que este ángulo amarillo y este
que tenemos aquí es de 61 grados pero la
suma de estos dos tienen que ser tiene
que ser 180 grados verdad estos dos
ángulos son suplementarios verdad es
decir su suma nos da 180 grados eso
quiere decir que este ángulo que aún no
conocemos debe ser 180 menos 61 grados
verdad y si a 180 grados le restamos 61
grados obtenemos el valor de este ángulo
que es de 119 gr 219 es igual a 180
menos 61 verdad entonces ahora con el
valor de este ángulo podríamos descubrir
el tercero que es el que nos interesa el
ángulo es ese y verdad éste era el
vértice y entonces cómo le hacemos bueno
pues la suma de los ángulos internos de
un triángulo de 180 grados es decir 27
más 119 más
ángulo desconocido es 180 eso quiere
decir que de hecho podríamos calcular lo
que este ángulo de aquí sería 180 menos
119 - 27 verdad eso eso es el valor de
este ángulo entonces 180 menos 119 eso
eso nos da 61 y luego a 61 le restamos
27 y nos da 34 grados muy bien entonces
el valor de este ángulo desconocido es
34 grados y como dije este problema se
puede resolver de muchas formas ahora
voy a borrar todo lo que hemos hecho
hasta este momento para tratar de
resolverlo usando algún otro método muy
bien entonces vamos a borrar todo esto
hasta ahí tenemos de vuelta el problema
inicial ahora en este en este caso vamos
a utilizar un método digamos vamos a
utilizar ángulos inscritos y nosotros
sabemos que si tenemos un ángulo
inscrito y que sostiene por ejemplo a
este diámetro que es ese verdad entonces
es este ángulo inscrito definido por los
vértices sl y en este ángulo de aquí va
a tener que ser un ángulo recto verdad
por qué pues porque es un ángulo
inscrito que sostiene a un diámetro
verdad entonces este ángulo es de 90
grados
y ahora podemos fijarnos en este
triángulo de aquí podemos fijarnos en
este triángulo definido por s y l verdad
de esos tres vértices y nuevamente
podemos utilizar el hecho de que la suma
de los ángulos internos de un triángulo
suman 180 grados verdad entonces tenemos
61 más 90 más este ángulo que no
conocemos verdad y eso nos debe dar 180
grados o bien esto esto es lo mismo que
decir que este ángulo vale 180 grados
menos este de aquí que es 90 grados
menos este de acá que vale 61 grados y
entonces qué es lo que tenemos 180 menos
90 nos da 90 y 100 90 le restamos 61 nos
da 29 grados verdad entonces este ángulo
de aquí mide 29 grados muy bien ahora lo
que vamos a hacer es fijarnos en este
otro triángulo en el triángulo definido
por los vértices
cl y entonces vamos a fijarnos en
en este triángulo de aquí verdad y
nuevamente nosotros conocemos este
ángulo es de 90 grados este ángulo de
aquí es de 27 grados y si podemos
calcular este ángulo de aquí verdad lo
estoy pintando muy grande pero bueno me
refiero a este ángulo que se encuentra
aquí entonces después digamos si
podríamos si pudiéramos calcular este
ángulo le quitamos 29 grados que es esta
parte naranja y obtenemos nuestro ángulo
deseado así que vamos a tratar de
descubrir cuánto vale este ángulo y
entonces tenemos que la suma de estos
tres ángulos son 180 grados aquí este es
de 90 este es de 27 y este es
desconocido entonces este de aquí este
ángulo que tenemos aquí sería 180 menos
90 menos 27 verdad ese es el valor de
este ángulo grande y entonces qué es lo
que tenemos 180 menos 90 son 90 y si a
90 le restamos 27
eso nos da 63 grados así que el valor de
este ángulo es 63 grados verdad entonces
si a este ángulo le restamos el ángulo
naranja obtenemos el ángulo que
buscábamos desde un inicio verdad así
que cómo vamos a hacerlo finalmente
vamos a tener 63 grados le vamos a
restar los 29 del del ángulo naranja
verdad y esto que nos da esto justamente
nos da 34 grados así que el ángulo que
buscábamos es de 34 grados en realidad
la forma en la que resolvía el problema
en esta ocasión pudo parecer un poco más
difícil y de hecho el primer método
parece ser más claro y fácil pero
siempre es bueno ver distintas formas de
cómo resolver un problema lo mejor a
otras personas se les ocurre otra forma
de resolverlo y es bueno tener varias
estrategias aquí esencialmente use la
idea de los ángulos inscritos verdad y
todo viene de que la medida del ángulo
inscrito es la mitad de la medida del
arco que define verdad
notemos que este arco que nos
consideramos aquí para decir que este
ángulo era de 90 grados este arco verdad
tiene una medida de 180 grados y por lo
tanto este ángulo inscrito mide 90
grados